hello everybody
i'm richard chen from nyu
and i'm going to talk to you today about
orchestrating the brain
for
social behavior
we have some ambitious questions and
goals facing us today
first
to delineate the goals of studies of the
brain
computation and behavior
and ask how they can be integrated with
each other
to describe how
oxytocin and other neuromodulators
transform circuits in the brain
and actually operate at a different
level than fast neurotransmitters
and finally to
take a more meta view of the whole
problem and evaluate the synergies and
challenges
of multi-level multi-investigator
projects
asking the question of how success in
these projects can be defined
it just so happens
that in this day and age of
pandemic
sheltering
two bucks crossed my desk in the last
week
one was a copy of principles of neural
science
the kandel textbook
to which i contributed a chapter
and secondly a book called noise by
nobel prize winning daniel kahneman and
his colleagues
these are two very different approaches
to
function of the brain
principles
is all about years of hard won knowledge
written about by many experts noise is a
much more popular oriented book trying
to describe how human judgment is
fallible
and subject to large amounts of
variation
both bias and variability and the point
is that if we could reduce that
variability
we would be much better off
whether we're trying to fight the
pandemic or simply buy a used car
so
my recollection of these problems goes
back to the early days of being a
graduate student and listening to a
marvelous lecture by colin blakemore
which mentioned
rene descartes
models of vision
rene descartes knew
that an object in the real world
got turned upside down
in terms of its image on the retiny
and he was worried about the fact that
this image was upside down
so he arranged the optic nerve
and its connections to
what he thought was the seat of
conscience consciousness the pineal
gland
by having
a reinversion of that image
so the image would project properly
upright onto the pineal gland
even as a graduate student i realized
that descartes was simply kicking the
problem down the road
because how did the pineal gland know
what to make of the uh
the image
and
was
the uh reinversion by
the nervous system in answer to the
question
a much more fundamental question of how
we saw
descartes had
equally metaphorical ways of looking at
memory
he saw memory
as the imprint produced by a set of
needles
that could make little holes in a piece
of canvas
and when the canvas was stretched out
the holes would become apparent
and the memory could be recalled
so this is a metaphorical view both the
vision
and of memory
and as it turns out these views these
could be thought of as a hypothesis for
how our brain processes information
stores it and recalls it
now the topic for today
is about oxytocin
this is a very interesting
chemical a nine amino acid peptide
produced in the hypothalamus of the
brain and release centrally and in the
periphery for example to
trigger the milk milk letdown reflex
oxytocin
consisting of nine amino acids is
conveniently shaped like the letter nine
an easy way to remember that
and
it's best known for its role
in
production of milk and childbirth so
it's really important for reproduction
but it's also implicated in many social
behaviors
social encounters
between people and between humans and
animals
cause an increase in oxytocin that could
be measured within a few minutes
so this is something that is highly
relevant to social behavior
oxytocin and its cousin vasopressin
signaling was shown to be important for
social behavior in rodents in prairie
voles and mountain bowls which differ
radically in the amount of oxytocin
receptor that they express in classic
experiments of larry young and tom insel
oxytocin has also been
tested as a possible clinical agent for
treatment of autism although the jury is
still out on this matter
so oxytocin really exemplifies the logic
of neuromodulation
the central nervous system uses fast
transmitters for example glutamate the
excitatory transmitter and acetylcholine
but it also has many neuromodulators
loosely defined as slower and less
directly acting agents which can be
peptides or even lipids and also small
molecules like glutamate and gaba
studying these molecules is extra
challenging because we not only need to
understand the neuromodulator how it's
produced and how it's act how it acts
but we also need to understand the basic
circuit that it acts upon
our hypothesis is
that neural circuits function at
multiple levels and they can be
transformed to have a different
personality
by the state of the neuromodulator
this idea was put forward for
invertebrate circuits for example in the
lobster by eve martyr and others but
it's never been fully worked out in
vertebrates and this whole idea of
modulating the existing operation of a
circuit and turning it into a different
kind of circuit is both powerful in
concept and has interes interesting
evolutionary aspects
oxytocin is a particularly interesting
example
and our goal today is to derive
principles
generalizable not only to
oxytocin but generalizable to other
neuromodulators and circuits
now in the brain
the receptors for oxytocin couple to
downstream g proteins
and the receptors are found unevenly
across the brain
one area where it's particularly
prominent is in the hippocampus in a
particular subfield of the hippocampus
called ca2
you can see that
in
this diagram which shows ca2 principal
neurons pyramidal cells
lit up because they're expressing
td tomato under the control of an
oxytocin receptor promoter
this indicates that ca2 is much richer
in oxytocin receptors than its
neighboring and more famous subregion
called ca1
the
oxytocin receptors in ca2 are
particularly interesting
because
they have been implicated in social
behavior in work from steve siegelbaum's
lab
and also
raman sahe showed that removing oxytocin
receptors from these neurons caused a
loss of social recognition
memory
driven by oxytocin was abolished
furthermore
oxytocin receptors are also present in a
particular
small but very interesting region of the
brain
called the ventral medial portion of the
hypothalamus
and the ventrolateral part of that so
these two small regions are very
important in diulin's work for
controlling aggression and they also
happen to be replete with oxytocin
receptors
so we obtained funding from nih uh uh
in the mechanism called the u19
and my principal investigators uh our
co-investigators are rob fromkey yuri
birjaki moses ciao
annette gray
daiyoulin
adamar and elisa circus and we're all at
nyu
in the neuroscience institute and in the
scurbal institute
we are the only u19 group of all the
ones that have been funded that are
working on modulation
and our institutional organization
favors collaboration between us
a special thanks to our all-star cast of
external advisors and to the nih
personnel listed on the first slide who
are both our advocates critics and
teachers
our
year 19 grant which is being presented
here is an example of a successful
large science collaboration
chose to focus on a number of regions of
the brain that express the oxytocin
receptor in abundance
oxytocin is shown here being released
from the hypothalamus
and it acts on the auditory cortex the
vm-hvl the hippocampus and the lateral
septum
and
as a result of the actions on the
auditory cortex
you can see in the upper right hand
corner effects on pup retrieval
as a result of actions on the vm hvl
also in the hypothalamus we see changes
in aggression but also changes in the
recognition of one's social rank
so we have taken a multi-disciplinary
approach with this anatomical backdrop
looking at synaptic plasticity in the
auditory cortex
looking at the transfer of information
from hippocampus to the lateral septum
looking at the
physiology of how ca2 principal cells
respond to oxytocin and use various g
proteins like gi and go to control their
ion channels and therefore their
membrane potential and cellular
excitability
and finally
looking at the
ventromedial hypothalamus
where certain oxytocin receptor
responding cells are really important
for
putting one
self in the totem pole of society
and of course these four main projects
are
very well supported by
cores that are involved in producing
antibodies to the oxytocin receptor in
doing behavioral studies
in managing data and sharing data and
finally in administration and
coordination headed by heather mckeller
so our principal investigators have many
years of collecting collective
experience among them
and here you see some of the papers we
published
just over the last period of funding
transformation of a spatial map across
the hippocampal lateral septal circuit
transformation of the firing pattern of
ca2 pyramidal cells
sexual dimorphic
aggressive behaviors
and neuromodulation of maternal circuits
by oxytocin
so i'm going to tell you about some very
exciting work
showing the involvement of oxytocin
neurons
in enabling
the social transmission of maternal
behavior
this is beautiful work coming from iwana
garcia now a junior faculty member at
rutgers
working with robert frumke one of our
principal investigators
so now i'm going to
show
a video
showing the behavior of a experienced
mother who will come and retrieve her
pup
so you will see
her leave the
nest detect the pup
who is giving out calls of distress
grab it by the scruff of the neck and
take it right back to the nest
let's contrast that with the behavior of
a female mouse that is not given birth
and is inexperienced
and you will notice
you will notice
that the inexperienced mouse
really pays the pup no mind
uh ignores its calls
and will just casually walk right past
it
without doing anything
now
this is the behavior whereby
the inexperienced animal becomes
experienced
with the tutelage
of the mother
who has a vested interest in getting
some babysitting help
by teaching the naive female
how to go back to the nest
and how to gather pups
so in this behavior
called shepherding
fromkey's lab
noticed through 24 7 recordings
that mothers
would shepherd
inexperienced females back to the nest
time after time after time and they
recorded
they recorded literally hundreds of
these events
now notably when the shepherding is
occurring
the oxytocin neurons in the
inexperienced neuron in inexperienced
female fire off madly and help it to
acquire the skills that it needs
so
this social transmission of maternal
behavior
consists first of all
of oxytocin neurons firing in the virgin
that is benefiting from the shepherding
that firing is critical for the
acquisition of retrieval skills
because if you
block the oxytocin neurons from firing
the retrieval skills are not gained
the block of oxytocin receptors prevents
the learning
and
mimicry
of the firing of oxytocin neurons
actually helps promote the learning
so
the pharmacological block of the
oxytocin receptors by a very specific
antagonist prevents the acquisition of
behavior
so this shows in a very dramatic way the
involvement of the oxytocin resistor
receptor system in the social
transmission of maternal behavior
so the practical strategies of our group
are
to combine top-down and bottom-up
approaches
24 7 recordings of analog behavior on
one hand
analysis of oxytocin receptor
distribution signaling and
electrophysiological effects on the
other hand
we do both of these approaches within
individual labs our labs are pretty
broadly spread within themselves and we
collaborate together
the behavior proceeds hand in hand with
mechanistic analysis
and it also draws upon advances in labs
outside of the u19 project
for example our colleague yulong lee
working in beijing has done an excellent
job of creating receptors for oxytocin
or
optical receptors for oxytocin that can
monitor the local oxytocin concentration
we capitalize on our close physical
proximity to each other all within a
large superblock of hospital
we synergize with other u19 groups and
other eu mechanisms for example groups
that are studying the role of
oscillations in behavior in primates
other groups that are interested in
synaptic plasticity
and the role of
brain oscillations
we combine experiments with computations
in theory
and we try to push technological
advances for example yuri berjaki has
been very active in
studying
ways of recording from hundreds of
thousands of neurons
and rob frumpke's lab is pioneering the
use of caged oxytocin
and we finally we use grant and paper
writing as a way of training our diverse
trainees
for example
my lab
has
many folks who are at the interface
between our project which is more about
the biophysics and circuit mechanisms
and we collaborate together with ishmael
xinjing is involved in that with rob
propane's lab we collaborate with the
bhajaki lab
via
his colleague we collaborate with
daiyulin's lab studying both female
aggression and social hierarchy we
collaborate with
paul glimpser's lab
kenway
louis and beau shen
and finally we are actively involved in
working with the oxytocin antibody core
and the behavioral optogenetics core so
all of these collaborations are driven
by trainees the trainees are very
diverse and we're very proud of their
ability to progress for example bianca
jones marlin got a job at columbia
katie eyring
won an f-99 k f99k00 and is now working
with dan geshwin at ucla
so to close
we have been
successful
in publishing a number of papers
including papers about plasticity in the
auditory cortex
papers about
the amygdala and its role in regulating
aggressive and sexual behavior
papers about the routing of hippocampal
oscillations to the lateral septum
and yuri the co-author of this
recently won the gerard prize of the
society for third of neuroscience
and finally my lab is interested in
molecular and cellular mechanisms and we
study how the synaptic plasticity might
be supported by synaptic vesicle traffic
so that ends part one
and if there were time i would go on to
part two but i think i'm going to call
it a day for today
and simply end the presentation here
simply to add that terry sinowski's
famous diagram about the many levels of
brain investigation stand as a challenge
to us whether we are following the
footsteps of renee descartes or not
and part of what we need to do
is to take the abundance of genetic data
on devastating disease
and
use it to help us understand how neurons
work as individuals how synapses
communicate because many of the genes
and code proteins involved in the action
of individual neurons are indeed
individual synapses
only now are we beginning to comprehend
how these genes and gene products are
orchestrated to guide behavior
and we believe that circuits are a
critical intermediate between cellular
and molecular neuroscience reaching down
to the level of genes and proteins and
systems neuroscience are
ranging all the way up to the brain uh
and uh and behavior
so thanks very much for uh listening to
me and i look forward to any questions
that you might send me my email address
is richard.tsien
at
nyumc.org thanks again